any questions yeah go ahead good morning
sir i am abhi gyatsu from gmv soon
producer and my question is sir would
you like to be immortal if someone finds
elixir
okay so you have to tell me your state
as well
okay all right
see the
the best thing about life
is death
and you may not think that
dying is so good
but if
if people live for very long time let's
say for example instead of living 70 80
years
we lived for 1000 years for example
so if that were to happen
or if we live for 2000 years
the world will look very different
and it will create a problem the
big problem it would create
is that
all the resources of the world
will get concentrated
in the hands of very few people
and
because what happens is that in a
lifetime
some people are really good at
making money and
gathering assets
they will keep gathering assets so right
now what happens is they you become an
adult in your 20s
and you are productive till you are 60
or 70 so you have 40 50 years
to
accumulate assets
but then what happens is that when you
die
uh basically
you cannot take anything
you can't even take a pin
right
so everything has to be left behind
and when everything is left behind
it
is basically recycled right now it could
go to your children
it could go some of it could go to the
government or it could go to society but
basically
it gets spread out right and then again
when those people die
and the people it goes to
may not be as good as you are in
accumulating
so they may not do as well so
the over time what will happen is
those resources will go back to society
but if someone lives for a thousand
years or ten thousand years
then
they will
they will accumulate
for a very long period of time and so a
few humans will be very smart about
doing that
and they will end up controlling
large portions of the resources
and
so like you know if you um
there's a there's a country which was
formed after the soviet union broke up
called kazakhstan
you may have heard of kazakhstan
kazakhstan is a very big country it's
bigger than all of europe
but only 18 million people so they're
not many people but
the land area is very large it's bigger
than india
and
when the
when the country was formed
everything used to be owned by the
government because it was a communist
country you know part of russia
but
after it was formed they
privatized some assets
put it in private time but it was done
very poorly
so
162 people in kazakhstan
control
more than 50 of all the wealth in the
country
so we have 18 million people
17.99 million don't have much
and a small number 162
and it's a very wealthy country it's a
rich country
so the
per capita
the per capita gdp of kazakhstan do we
have a marker
over there
so if you you can give that to me so
like the
you know the
the population of kazakhstan is uh 18
million and i'll write it american style
with the commas
the per capita income
is ten thousand dollars per person it's
a very rich country
india per capita is less than two
thousand
okay
so if i take this and multiply it you
get uh
you'll get 180 billion
okay
and
it could divide by two cardo
so 90 billion okay
and if we divide this by 162
what is that number
of
if it's 100
and
that's going to be
900 million
per person
if there was if it was divided by 100
if we divide by 200
then this will be
450
right
so what is it when you divide by 162
like
700
650 600 something like that
it's a large number
each of those people
has 450 million dollars
those 75 is a multiplier
so
450
so
this would be the money in indian rupees
per person approximately or maybe you
can make it a little bit less because
it's 75 you'd make it about 350.
right and so basically i know actually
it's higher because it's uh going the
other way so closer to 550.
so it's like uh let me just do this
correctly 550
0 0 0
0 and then i got 2 more zeros
so 55
so it is the
55 billion rupees
very big number
per person
that's a problem
so recently in kazakhstan what happened
is they raised the tax
on
petrol
petrol
so the
17.99 million people are saying
yeah 162 login
common person say or personally
so they were riots in the streets
and they said we are going to throw all
you guys out
and
immediately five minutes later the
government said there's no tax increase
they said we don't care about that we
still want to take you guys out
so now the government is trying to put
taxes on the rich people
and they're telling they called all the
rich people and said
charities
so anyway the thing is that if we were
to basically
not die
then this would happen all over the
world
that the wealth would get more and more
concentrated and then
so
when you ask me personally
if i knew that i was going to live even
for 200 years
right let's say i knew i was going to
live for 200 years
i would not have started dakshina
right
dakshina started when i was
42 years old
right the reason i started dakshina when
i was 42 years old is
because do you know the
the date i'm going to die
when am i going to die please raise your
hand
every time i meet the
dakshina scholars i tell them
[Music]
the date i'm going to die
so
the date i'm going to die
is june 11 2044.
so
there are 22 years left
how many years 20
20 22
and and 22 years and three weeks and
what's the origin of this number why why
why have you picked this number
so the thing is that most humans
almost all humans
never think about their death
they don't think about when they're
gonna die and they don't think about
kind of let's say planning okay
so uh
so that
i did an exercise that part of a ypo
retreat where they
where they said to us okay you're 80
years old and yesterday you died
and your best friend is going to deliver
a eulogy
so write your eulogy as if you're your
best friend and deliver it in five
minutes
to the other members
so i was 40 years old when i did the
exercise so i had 40 years to make up
because i've tried to extrapolate how
many grandkids i have and what's going
on in my life the next 40 years then the
second part of the exercise after we did
all of this was
is
they said that
if something did not make your eulogy
in that five minutes
why are you spending time on it
and that was very profound for me you
know so basically it inverted where you
look back and say what's important
and so that exercise is a couple of
things one is the framing once you know
that you have
a certain amount of time
then it
makes a lot of things clear
uh
i mean like like for example you know my
uh
my designer here was telling me that our
kitchen should get redone you know this
home is like 16 years old or something
and if we have to redo the kitchen we
probably have to move out for six months
or something you know because
all this stuff
and to me it was really simple i'm not
willing to disrupt six months of my life
when there's 22 years left that ratio
makes no sense to me so i know the
kitchen's not going to get rid of
period end of story okay if by some
accident i'm away for six months which
is not planned because of kitchen
maybe we'll think about it okay so it
made that decision really easy if i had
not
had that kind of framing
i might have said oh yeah you know this
would be nice to have and this would be
better or whatever else but it just made
the decision a no-brainer it also made
it very clear to me
that i won't move again
i said i'm i have 22 years left i don't
want to spend time moving it's just a
waste of time and and so the 22 years
makes a lot of things really simple it
also makes it simple when you meet some
yo-yo for lunch that you're not going to
meet them again because there's only 22
years left how many yo-yos do you want
to tolerate and i talked to guy about
this and guy has an infinite number of
tolerance for yo-yos and i'm trying to
work on that with him but i haven't made
much progress yet
so i think the framing the 22 years
makes a lot of decisions easy
hmm
[Music]
you